Asalam alaikum Dr. Zakit
welcome to our city.
Your
>> name and your profession brother? My
name is Ji Prasio. Uh my profession
actively learning and explore content
uh
and technology online.
>> Okay. Can you post your question
briefly?
sentence. How was the way Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him approached
business and investment in his time? And
what is your view on the modern trend
where many influencer promote
cryptocurrency
especially Bitcoin
as the fast way to become rich?
Is this aligned with Islamic teachings?
>> Brother has a question. How did Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam deal
with business earning money? Is
cryptocurrency
what's my view on crypto cryptocurrency?
How can you get rich fast? Correct.
>> Yes.
>> Mhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam was a
business. He was a messenger of Allah.
Number one, he was a D and he was also a
businessman.
He did business
and if you read the s of the prophet
initially of course he used to take the
caravans
of hazat khijah may Allah be pleased
with her he was a very successful
businessman mashallah regarding a
question what the prophet gave what you
read in the Quran and the hadith are
guidelines for doing business
that when you do business do not deal in
ribba.
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter 2 verse number 275 do not deal
in ribba but they say ribba is like
business tell them business is permitted
ribba is haram interest so dealing in
interest is haram do not lie do not
cheat bakar 2 verse 188 do not use your
wealth as bait for judges in order to
eat other people's wealth do not bribe
so there are various guidelines See to
it that when you measure and weigh you
do not cheat in that. When you measure
in length do not cheat in that. There
are various guidelines. You can give a
lecture on this. For doing business
there are various guidelines.
And unfortunately many Muslims are not
aware of the Islamic guidelines in
business. There are many Muslims who
doing business and they're doing haram
for years. They're making money but they
don't know it is haram.
For example, today itself I was speaking
to someone from Dubai and one of my
business is buying and selling cars.
So tell me Dr. Zakir tell me how much
you want to sell your car for. I say
okay I want to sell for 300,000. Okay
whatever above I sell I'll take it. I
said that's not allowed. Why? I'm giving
you what you want. commission is allowed
in Islam. But if he's not the owner, he
says, "Okay, I will sell for 350,000.
I'll keep the 50,000 in my pocket." This
is normal in society accepted.
Logically, now I want to sell for 300.
He gets a customer for 350. He keeps the
50,000 for himself. Logically, it may
sound to be normal. Right or wrong? But
Islamically, it's haram. What does Islam
say? You are misguiding the buyer. The
buyer doesn't know that you want to sell
for 300,000. You sell for 350,000.
You're keeping 50,000. That means you're
cheating the buyer. So in Islam, he can
buy the car from me. Pay me my full
300,000 then sell for 400, 500. That's
his business. So you cannot sell
something which you do not own. So in
this aspect there are hundreds of laws
in business. I cannot he'll have to I
have to give a talk for us together. You
understand?
So there are rules for business. Should
not cheat, should not bribe, should not
differ in weights, in measurement.
Various rules are there. You cannot hold
something and increase the price. If
it's a necessity, you cannot hold rice
and increase the price. Yes, if it is a
luxury, you can. So there are guidelines
in Islam for various things. I'll come
to your question on cryptocurrency. As
far as cryptocurrency is concerned, it's
a digital currency that was launched a
few years ago. As far as crypton
cryptocurrency is concerned, as of now,
majority of the scholars, they say
because it is doubtful, better to stay
away from it. Except for certain
scholars like Dr. Daw Bakr, he's also an
expert in Islamic economics. He comes
from Malaysia. So Malaysia is one of the
countries where they did research and
they say okay if these certain criteria
fit and doesn't go against the Quran
cryptocurrency is permitted. But the
other scholars very few say it's haram
but majority say because the nature is
doubtful because of the blockchain etc.
It is not very confirmed. It is a
doubtful area gray area. Stay away from
it. So as of now even I'm into business.
Anyone ask me I cannot say for sure it
is haram. I cannot say for sure it is
halal. So I yet agree with the majority
group of scholars who say stay away from
it in cryptocurrency because there are
various gray areas in it. Tomorrow when
we get more clarification we can
classify whether halal or whether haram.
But today because it's a gray area and
the prophet said when you're in doubt
leave it out. There are thousands of
businesses you can do. You ask me how to
get rich fast. Correct.
You asked me the question how to get
rich fast correct
>> yes correct
>> best solution best solution offer five
times salah and don't miss your tourna
before the fud
>> yes
yes
>> you know why you know people when they
have the listing of top
>> top 10 richest people in the world
>> wait brother let me give the answer
first
>> I'm giving the answer you're saying
young people
>> young people
>> I'm giving The answer can do
>> you know in the list of top 10 richest
people. Okay. Number four is Bill Gates.
Number two Jeff Bis. So number three
Jeff Bis number two Elon Musk. Who's
number one?
A Muslim who prays to Salah fajar Salah?
He's richer.
Because the prophet said the two sunnah
of fajar salah is more valuable than the
earth and the wealth in it.
People come a I have a four time salah.
Fudger salah I miss. I said why? I can't
get up in the morning.
Every other salah I pray on time. Fudger
I can't get up. So I told him you know
okay you're a businessman. Suppose I
tell you tomorrow morning there is a
business deal morning 5:00
>> in which you'll get $1 million will you
attend the deal? You said yes but you
but you can't get up in the morning. No
no no $1 million I won't sleep also.
So for $1 million you cannot sleep the
taka sunnah and the prophets that is
more valuable than the word in the
wealth in it. What is the value of the
fud? Salah think
the problem is we hear the hadith but we
don't believe in it. We read the Quran
we don't believe in it. Allah says
so I tell I will never miss my fud even
my sunnah I will not miss. Even if
someone gives me a million dollar
yes it's not farther to offer sunnah.
What you have to understand that if you
really believe in it, you know which is
the best business. Allah says in surah
bakra chapter 2 verse number 261 if you
give one grain in the way of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala Allah will give you
seven years seven bha each year having
100 grain that mean one grain becomes
700 times.
Allah is telling Allah will give you 700
times profit. In business terminology
70,000%
profit. How much?
70,000%.
700 times is equal to 70,000%
profit. Do you know any business in
which you get 70,000% profit?
Do you know, brother? Yeah. Do you know
any business in which you get 70,000%
profit?
No, no.
>> Your mind has gone bonkers.
>> Oh, no.
>> 10% prophet, 20% prophet, 100% prophet,
200, 70,000% prophet.
We read the Quran, we say we believe in
Allah. Wallah, we don't believe.
You're talking about young person doing
business. My son 2 three years back he
started doing business.
So I told him my son in your business
make Allah your partner. He said you
okay Abba and when you make Allah your
partner you cannot make Allah your small
partner. Correct? So make him minimum
51% partner. So whatever profit you get
minimum give 51% in charity.
How much?
>> 50.
>> 50. Not 50. 51.
>> 51.
>> 51 means the greater partner is Allah.
I told my son you are starting business.
Minimum whatever profit you make if you
make in a year $100,000
give 50,000 $51,000 minimum. I give more
because I'm better. I'm old. So I give
more. I won't tell you how much I give.
And the more you give, the more you get
remaining. You know in Bombay we had a
staff of 500 people working. In Bombay
in our Dava office we had 500 people
working full-time.
I used to tell my employees whether
they're poor, medium or rich give
charity start according to Islam for
this minimum 2 and a half% if you have a
saving of more than the sub level. If
you have more than 85 gram of gold
minimum you have to give 2.5% that is
fat. Above that is sunnah. The more you
give the better it is. I tell my staff
okay you start start with 10%.
So my lowest staff maybe he has a salary
of 10,000 rupees. Now 10,000 rupees of
India is more it not 10,000 rupee of of
of Indonesia. Indian rupees is 190
multiply. So 10,000 would be 10,000
would be 100,000 1 million 19 million or
yeah 1.9 million. So 10,000 rupees would
be 1.9 million if your salary
okay start
in Indonesia suppose your salary is 2
million rup rup okay if 10% charity so
if you 10% charity you give out of 2
million rup how much is remaining with
you
18 million now when you give 10% charity
Allah increases your salary so your
salary from 2 million now would become
2.5 million million.
If for 2 and a2 million you give 10%
what's remaining with you is 22 and a2
million much more than what you had
before correct then you start giving 15%
charity Allah will increase your salary
to 35 million
keep on giving more and more
even though you're poor zakat is not f
you give in the way of Allah Allah will
give you Allah promises in the Quran
basically we Muslims we say we love
Allah We trust in Allah but we don't
trust.
Allah says give charity.
And I've seen that I'm a D correct. I
spend about maybe two days in a month.
Less than half an hour a day I spend on
my business. I've got 10 businesses.
I make million dollar
a year. Millions of dollar we make and
majority I give in charity. No problem.
I don't require it.
I'm a full-time D. On average, I work
for about 13 14 hours a day. Out of the
half and half a business.
Allah is my bigger business partner. I
will not tell you what percentage. Allah
takes care of my business. No problem.
The more I invest, Allah gives. No
problem.
So we have to make your lifestyle
simple. Don't show off with the money
you have. Give it in charity. Give to
Gaza. Give to the poor people. you get
more happiness.
Correct? So if you do otherwise you see
other businessmen okay they want a car
BMW
Mercedes Mayback Lamborghini Bentley
Rolls-Roy
these are nothing when you start loving
Allah this is all kach for you dirt one
lie all dirt when you reach a level with
Allah the person who a billionaire he
cannot travel in the car unless it is
Mercedes unless it's Lamborghini they
are depend dependent I've given the talk
on what is the purpose of your life and
I've discussed in detail about these
things we have seen all these things we
have used all these things useless so
when you do business make Allah your
business okay anyway this is just my
advice I'm not saying this is fur Islam
please fur Islam is zakat 2.5% of your
excess wealth every year this is a
solution on how to get rich
no dron earning 2 million. If I give 1
million, what will happen to me? Allah
will test you. Try it out for few
months. See the result?
Understand?
>> Yes.
>> But people say yes but they don't
follow.
Say yes but they don't follow. I'm not
telling start with 51%. You know I don't
know what you are. Start with 10%. Make
it 20. Make it 30. Make it 40. Make it
50. Make it 60. Best is to do business
with Allah. Make Allah your business
partner. Inshallah you will never go in
loss. In Akra you'll get Allah says 700
times.
700 times I am a living example.
You know how the D.
I told the organizers no one should
charge ticket.
Most of the Islamic Dies they want money
to come. Correct. I come with my own
money. I come with my own ticket. I got
40 people from Malaysia, from India. I
paid the ticket. No problem. You
understand? Why? Because Allah is my
business partner.
I don't want anyone to come here for
paying money. I never take any fees for
my lecture. People are willing to give
me $10,000, $100,000. Sometime 1% off
million dollar. I said how? I will make
1 million, you make 1 million. I said,
no, I'm happy with what I've got here.
I'm making millions like that only. Why
should you charge from the um it has
become a trend in the western world.
You're charging for entry. What is this?
If the Sabbath and our prophet started
charging for Islamic lectures, would we
become Muslims? No.
It's not haram to charge. But you're
making it a business.
If you're working and taking salary, no
problem. But it has become a business.
Organizers make they spend money and
they share with the speaker. What is
this? Therefore these organizers
mashallah see Allah help them all this
they're doing the um is strong in the
Muslim um see the Islamic setup it's
good or bad
>> mashallah yet free correct
>> who supporting Allah it's the
Indonesians who are giving I did not
give money for this I can give but
doesn't look at me and coming and making
the stage they told Dr. Because is
coming people started donating see
mashallah
my criteria was free no one should
charge one business how much you want
they can't see this
so we have to trust in Allah do dawa
professionally
you know my rosroy where is my rosy
these cameras
do you know this camera is more
expensive than my rosoy do you know that
>> no I know
>> one one camera is costing $300,000
A cheap Rolls-Roy is less than $300,000.
Now this is my Rolls-Roy.
We are spending in the way of Allah.
So we are proud that we want to use the
best of technology for dav'awa.
And when you use best of technology for
dava, Allah gives you.
So we spend in the way of Allah, Allah
will give you multiple times more. Hope
that answers the question. Let's go.
Thank you.